[Music]  you know it seems like every day there's  a new funny cat video that's gone viral  these things are everywhere every day  there's a new one people say oh you got  to check it out  the latest one that's been making the  rounds is a cat peeking over the top of  a bed yeah it's I loved it check it out  slub that  anyway I thought that was fantastic did  you think so Andy I guess what is wrong  with you you don't like cat videos oh no  no it's not that I mean cat videos are  great it just it bugs me because my cat  is really boring he will never go viral  you're saying your cats boring yeah he's  in my dressing room right now take a  look he's on camera  [Applause]  [Music]  what's wrong with your cat's paws they  seemed he has arthritis little  I wouldn't explain why it's coming in at  that angle though it's cat arthritis  yeah I got